the snow covering hides the fact that
this is an enormous rubbish tip
stretching as far as the eye can see in
every direction at its center the active
dump site 100 metres high
it's simply vast on it like worker ants
humans scavenge for anything they can
find but this is inside Europe today
these aren't refugees or economic
migrants these are Romania Spore an
underclass reduced to scratching out a
living from this waste filming inside
the dump is strictly prohibited but one
of the workers was prepared to take our
camera inside to see what it's like and
to get a sense of just how miserable
this place really is men women and
children make up the scavenging teams
government and private contractors own
all the wastes here the scavengers crows
as they are known have paid a tiny cut
to collect recyclable waste once they
could take it away themselves to sell
not now there are economic slaves
effectively tied to live like this this
wasteland is a throwback to the Soviet
era toxic waste was dumped here as well
it's gas still leaks into the air today
the nauseous vapors are a constant local
snake illness is never far away the
smell of rotten garbage it kills you you
cannot stay outside more than one minute
so you have to wear a mask so you can
stay outside for the people close to the
toxic waste I cannot say how they feel
or how sick they are I always seek and
they they cannot afford to go to the
doctor or to hospital because they don't
have insurance
the community surrounding the dump a
squalid five years ago the inhabitants
were evicted from their homes in the
center of the city of Cluj and made to
live here on the outskirts along the
railway tracks towards the dump site the
families live amongst the filth ten of
them share this room all ages all in
together now living conditions put a new
spin on the term basic they burn off the
hair of the pig before it be prepared
for eating
nothing is ever left a local leader gave
us permission to film on his territory
and showed us around they are by and
large Roma a gypsy race originally from
northern India who moved to Europe over
a thousand years ago outsiders are
welcome and even with permission tension
these Romanians demand equal rights but
theirs is a life of segregation
condemned to a life of the outsider at
home health care education work
opportunities are simply denied to
simply segregating marginalism unit we
feel Romanians I am a Romanian because I
was raised in Romania and I live in
Romania but the Romanians don't don't
affect me accept me like a Romania they
feel they discriminated us and
segregated you see and do you feel like
that as well even though you perhaps
done better than many yes I feel like
that because even if I say I'm a
Romanian the Romanian say you're not a
remaining or ajussi the traditional
gypsy say I or not gypsy your God yo so
so you're somewhere in the middle in the
gray area Tony Novak speaks Romanian
English Italian and German he taught
himself he works when he can in the
United Kingdom he says he can't get a
job out here because of who he is more
difficult because we live here and the
people when they find out I live here is
and this is this is very much the point
because of where you actually lived yes
that you would be linked to the Roma
people yes basically actually end up
working exactly when they find out
because at the first they don't they are
not interested by the guy but if state's
two or three months they dig we've come
from where you live which which are your
neighbours and go on nobody wants to
live and work in a place like this but
these people have no choice and is
little wonder that they would like to go
somewhere else in many ways there's
little difference between then and the
refugees and economic migrants currently
pouring into Europe except of course one
major difference they're already in
Europe they're Europeans but they enjoy
none of the benefits the rest of us take
for granted
on the busy streets have Cluj Romania
second city there is little concern for
the poorest members of their society for
its part the local authorities deny
discrimination arguing rather that the
crows the scavengers choose to live
outside normal society people just
expect everybody to follow the same
rules they do and to cope with the same
problems they do and expect to have the
same chances and opportunities they do I
think in terms of local mentality this
is the the general idea some take all
the responsibilities and the
opportunities and rights that comes with
belonging to a community community some
don't so I think it's in that may be a
matter of choice for years human rights
groups have criticized Romania for its
treatment of these people but as this
country's European partners prepare to
allocate refugees across the member
states there's growing concern here over
how the refugees will be treated when
Romania is underclass is condemned to
live like this already mr. Ramsay Sky
News Cluj Romania